that's right you know what that is
that's how many you reviewers movie
awards there are about to be welcome to
the nominations for the fourth annual
you reviewers movie awards I know there
are a lot of new subscribers here this
year so a lot of people are like what's
that you reviewers movie awards we
freaked out in 2011 me and the schmoes
from schmoes Nobby got together we were
like let's do a YouTube movie review
show you know for the fans because they
love that stuff and we loved it we'll
all love it together seemed a match made
in heaven so we did it and we've done it
every year since now this is the fourth
year we're doing it in the you reviewers
Movie Awards a bunch of YouTube movie
reviewers get together and they nominate
movies in their categories you know how
award shows work and then in the actual
show YouTube movie reviewers present in
categories it's a lot of fun and we have
something cool for you guys the fans
this year I'll tell you when we get to
the category of Best Picture I'm just
saying in this video here's actually
half of all the nominations you want to
see the other half go to the schmoes
know YouTube channel they will have the
other half of the nominations that being
said let's get into this half of the
nominations and the nominees are for the
category if I'm shocked it didn't suck
this is the movies you thought they were
gonna suck and ended up not sucking the
nominees are Olympus has fallen World
War Z warm bodies The Wolverine and oz
the great and powerful next category
best soundtrack slash score someone call
it music we have American hustle
followed by gravity then we have her
then inside Llewyn Davis and Man of
Steel and now we're on Best Supporting
Actress and I'm gonna let you know there
are about three people I can think of in
this entire video whose names I hope I
pronounce I'm right for Best Supporting
Actress we have Lupita and Jung know
from 12 years of slave Margot Robbie
from wolf of wallstreet Jennifer
Lawrence in American hustle June Squibb
in Nebraska and Julia Roberts in Osage
County I want to say Orange County it's
not though it's not that Osage Oh yield
sage County Best Supporting Actor we
have Jonah Hill in wolf of wallstreet
Michael Fassbender in 12 years of slave
Daniel Bruhl in Rush Jared Leto in
Dallas buyers club and introducing
barkhad Abdi from Captain Phillips best
comedy the movies that made us laugh all
year we have the World's End
followed by this is the end then we have
wolf of wallstreet followed by anchorman
- killing it off with bad grandpa now
under the category of Best Actress Best
Actress we have Amy
in American hustle cate blanchett in
blue jasmine and the Thompson for saving
mr. banks Julie Delpy in before midnight
and Sandra Bullock in gravity on to best
actor for best actor we have Leonardo
DiCaprio in wolf of wallstreet Matthew
McConaughey in Dallas buyers club and
probably a few other movies she Mattel
Ejiofor in 12 years of slave Tom Hanks
for captain Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix
for her for Best Director we have David
O'Russell for American hustle say that
three times fast because I can't Martin
Scorsese for wolf of Wall Street
Alfonso kiloohm for gravity Spike Jonze
gave us her and Steve McQueen gave us 12
years of slave Best Picture here it is
and this is actually a pretty special
category but the nominees are prisoners
Place Beyond The Pines American hustle
the wolf of Wall Street followed by mud
then we have 12 years of slave then on
to gravity then we're giving you her
bringing us to Dallas buyers club
finishing it off with Captain Phillips
and like I said Best Picture is a very
special category for you guys this is an
ever growing and evolving concept and we
really wanted to involve you guys this
year so if you go to the schmoes no
website I put a link below where you can
find the poll you guys you right there
my finger is pointing at you then you
can do this from the list of nominees
nominated by your YouTube movie
reviewers you guys vote for best picture
of the year for the fourth annual you
reviewers movie awards a movie with the
most votes by you that's best picture of
the year like I said we really wanted to
get you guys involved so there you go go
there nominate pick choose only one vote
per person don't be greedy so there it
is there are half of your nominations I
hope you guys have fun voting you can
catch the other half of the nominations
on the schmoes know youtube channel go
there check it out your reviewers movie
award should be fun it should be a
collaborative effort it should be the
embodiment of why we're all here because
we all like talking about movies we're
all passionate about it we're all a
group of movie nerds and it's awesome
and it would end this with a question
but in the end I'll just say go vote I
just want you guys to exercise this new
thing I'm glad we got to bring this to
you guys and keep an eye out because the
schmoes know and I will bring you the
you reviewers movie awards divided among
our channels as always around the Oscars
I don't make no promises but we like
doing it before the Oscars cuz snipe in
the Oscars just feels like a victory for
the people
giving you an official date I can say
around Oscar time we will bring you the
4th annual year reviewers Movie Awards
so in the end as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more David
O'Russell for american hustle david o
russell for american hustle david or
Russell for american hustle david l
wrestle for american wow I can do that